James is starting off this hour and
Pecos Texas hi James welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey how's it going good how
are you I'm doing pretty good I just
started listening to you here recently
by chance because well it's the only
radio station I get out here you're my
brother so every day I've got you on the
radio I guess my question is I make
about 140 thousand a year I currently
have 91 thousand dollars rick is dead
but I really really really need to
replace my house you know where do I
start to paying off to be able to
achieve the goal of getting the house
the catch is 50,000 of that debt is my
land which is a part of my inheritance I
don't have to pay that immediately that
can be paid at any kind what's the other
40 an RV and two trucks and what's
what's the RV I use for work so I have
to have it how do you use an RV for work
I'd live wherever I work my company pays
me to use my own my own housing I just
move it wherever I work to action okay
and so you're married then yes sir okay
and what's the emergency on your house
my current house is just I mean it's
falling apart it's a 3-bedroom I've got
four kids it's too old I'm constantly
having to fix broken pipes and walls and
door jams and it's just that the state
needs to go so single wide trailer house
oh I really need a double-wide okay well
let's start with this I you're not wise
to invest in mobile homes because they
go down in value none of them go up in
value so no you don't need a double-wide
is this land is this home the land that
you inherited the family land yes okay
so what we need to do is start working
towards you building a home
that's what we need to do you make
$140,000 a year let's build a house okay
and you know just get rid of the junky
single-wide all right because that
double-wide you pay 70 for it in in five
years is worth nothing
right right yeah we don't it's gone the
wrong white dude when I go up not down
so in the house would go up in value so
of course you're probably not in the
market sell any of this stuff anyway
with it being all family Lynn but either
way the land is in your name right I'm
sorry I said it'll stay in the family
forever yeah so the land is in your name
though right yes okay this particular
portion of the land all right good all
right well here's the thing the first
thing is that you jump on every dollar
and download the app your wife does the
same thing I'm going to put you into
what we call Financial Peace University
I'm going to pay for it okay it's $129
to go through the class but I'm gonna
give it to you and you both can watch
the videos even if you're separated from
her by work because the whole thing's a
home line and/or where is the home
where's the family property where she
lives good okay well she also can attend
the classes I don't know if there'll be
one near you the way you're describing
where you are but there's about 12 or 13
thousand of the classes operating in
churches out there so she can attend the
classes too but you both can follow
along and both be doing the lessons at
the same time because it's totally
online all right I'm gonna give that to
you and so's the every dollar app now
that means the two of you are both
working your budgets together even
though you're separated by several
hundred miles okay a lot of military
families do this when someone is
deployed in other words so we're used to
doing this with couples that are living
like you guys are now once we're doing
all of that we've got every dollar
behaving in a certain way then the only
question is what is the best order to do
things what's first what's second to hit
your goals okay a hundred and forty
thousand dollars a year 90 thousand
dollars but 50 of it is the
and okay correct and so what I would do
is look at selling the 40 want much do
you own your Kruk mmm my truck that I
use for work is 25,000 and then my wife
struck out 6,000 okay see if a 25,000
our truck that you got out in the
workplace destroying it geez man okay
that probably needs to be downgraded to
about a six thousand dollar truck to and
then you're living in the RV so we're
gonna list all your debts not counting
the farm forty thousand dollars when you
look at a hundred and forty versus forty
I'm saying you're paying all this off
not counting the farm you're not in
probably a year but you're gonna be on
beans and rice rice and beans and so's
the family back home and we're we have
this goal of getting all these trucks
and RVs paid off because if you had no
payments except the land you'd be in
shape to go get a construction loan that
would pay off the land and build you a
house okay that's that's about a year
and a half two years away with what I'm
talking about and the family just lives
the way they've been living in the
meantime or worse and we get out of that
you do whatever it takes to clear all
these debts because that sets you up
because man think about if you have no
payments you've got money right well I
just started this new job prior to that
we were okay seriously paycheck to
paycheck so I'm just this new
opportunity here good I'm hoping there's
an opportunity to get this stuff paid
off there you go and that's not gonna
happen accidentally it's going to be
with a detailed plan of attack what do
you do what do you do i do flow back
okay and that and that's very detailed
with an exact game plan to create an
exact reaction an exact result that you
want you don't do this it you don't you
don't pull off your job accidentally
right right it's cause and effect and
that's what this thing I'm talking about
is you're going to crank down
nothing on the expenses and you're going
to keep making you cranked up your
income and that what that's what sparked
the conversation and we're gonna clean
up this dadgum mess and then you know
get a plan drawn to build a house and
get a builder lined up and start talking
about building a nice home on this and
that pays off the 50,000 inside that
construction loan as well so then all
you end up with at the end of story is a
mortgage and on a 15-year fixed-rate and
you're gonna walk your way right through
that